all of this leads up to the simple fact
that joe biden is in trouble and so he
is going to go back to the well and that
well for democrats as always is everyone
who opposes me as a vicious racist now
this worked better for barack obama
because he was the first black president
joe biden is whiter than the back side
of the sheet of paper i'm currently
holding up joe biden is one of the
whitest people in america he's an 80
year old white man who is now who by the
way served in the senate with people
like george wallace
and
talked about how he had been praised by
people like george wallace in the 70s
not kidding okay so so joe biden goes
down to georgia
and he decides that he is going to
rant and rave about how republicans are
trying to steal elections now i have to
say this is truly incredible it really
is so we've been hearing since november
of 2020 that it was the quote unquote
big lie right this is the media have
used the term big lie to apply to donald
trump's contention that the 2020
election was stolen i don't believe that
donald trump won the election
or that joe biden lost the won the
election on the basis of electoral fraud
i think there are a lot of things in the
election that were extremely corrupt i
think that the rejiggering of election
law in pennsylvania contrary to the
pennsylvania state constitution was
corrupt i think in any election with 155
million votes you're gonna get some
voter fraud i think that the media lied
i think the media prevaricated i think
they covered up for joe biden's failures
i think that they printed overt
falsehoods about donald trump i think
all of that can be true and i still
think that the 2020 election was not
quote unquote stolen in the way that
donald trump means it was stolen the
media however labeled that the big lie
now the reason they used the term big
lie is it is amazing the same media that
will say you can never make a holocaust
comparison a contention with edge with
which i generally agree they're
consistently making
holocaust language comparisons when they
say the big lie what they mean is like
hitler's big lie and they are implicitly
comparing the two there is no question
that's what they are doing in the same
way that when they call you a climate
change denier they're essentially trying
to hijack the language of holocaust
denial that is the goal the goal is to
take some of the most charged language
with regard to human communication and
then to slide it into all of the
american political domestic talk
so donald trump was engaged in the big
lie over november of 2020. well i have a
question if it was a big lie for donald
trump to say that the election of 2020
was stolen through voter fraud
what would you say if i told you that
the democrats are now contending that
every election for the rest of time is
about to be stolen by republicans
that's what they're contending they're
now contending that if the republicans
are not stopped they will steal every
election for the rest of time which
implicitly means that if republicans win
democrats are going to challenge the
results of the election saying that the
election was stolen
i know that we're supposed to pretend
this is only a one-sided thing it is not
a one-sided thing stacy abrams from
georgia contended that the election for
governor a few years back was stolen
from her even though she lost by 50 000
votes that is not
donald trump's 12 000 votes in georgia
that's four times the margin 50 000
votes she lost by in georgia and she
still contended that the election was
stolen from her and this has become part
and parcel of the democratic playbook in
2020 i know that we're supposed to just
erase the history prior to november of
2020 of the election but you will recall
that it was democrats who were claiming
pretty openly that if donald trump won
it was because he cheated
in fact post 2016 democrats claim for
four years that donald trump won because
he cheated so now the new big lie okay
if we're gonna call it the big lie that
republicans lost the election of 2020 at
the presidential level because of voter
fraud
i'm going to say it's the biggest lie to
say that every election for the rest of
time will be stolen by republicans
unless joe biden gets to completely
rewrite election law in the united
states from the federal level that is
the biggest lie you can't imagine a
bigger lie what would the bigger lie be
really
if i say that one election was stolen
and that's untrue and then you say all
elections i lose are stolen all of them
which one is the bigger lie and yet the
media has no problem whatsoever just
trotting out joe biden's propagandistic
bull crap it's unreal
there's less evidence that voter
suppression is a massive problem in the
united states far less evidence that
voter suppression is a problem in the
united states and that there is some
element of voter fraud in elections
voter fraud is a minor issue as
far as percentages of the total vote
and voter suppression is a non-issue
because it is a federal crime to
suppress the votes you stop people
actively from voting you can't do that
so what the hell are they talking about
this is the pitch and the pitch really
is to black americans
that if you don't stop the republicans
the republicans are going to stop you
from voting and we're going to go right
back to jim crow joe biden by the way is
not being subtle about this joe biden
has been saying for
a year at this point the republicans are
pursuing a new jim crow in the south
which is patently insane there's
currently a black democratic senator
from the state of georgia
stacy abrams is a real contender to be
governor of georgia
after being a terrible politician for
the past several years with regard to
the lies that she has told
joe biden
he's constantly bragging about the
election results and then it it's so it
is wild i mean on the same at the same
time you have republicans many
republicans were like yeah the election
of 2020 was stolen sure i got elected to
a seat in congress in that same election
but the election was stolen
joe biden does the exact same thing he's
like i won the election of 2020 but but
voter suppression is a real thing
barack obama won the elections of 2008
2012 but voter suppression is a real
threat
and what are you talking about what are
you talking about again the idea is
everyone who opposes joe biden is a
vicious racist now here's the thing
nobody actually believes this
there's pulling out from morning console
today and uh and morning console polling
shows that americans literally do not
care about any of the issues joe biden
is talking about he's not talking to
anybody except his base and in fact even
members of his base are not willing to
to hear this because they understand
that this is incredibly stupid so stacy
abrams actually skipped joe biden's
speech in georgia last night she skipped
it she was like nope
an aide for abrams told the new york
times she was unable to attend the event
in atlanta
despite her absence abram's expressed
support for the event welcoming biden
back to georgia on twitter yeah there's
a reason she didn't show up and maybe it
has to do with the fact that joe biden
is a 30 approval president in the state
of georgia and any attachment to joe
biden kills her in the state of georgia
joe biden had some words about this uh
he says that it was a scheduling mix-up
yeah joe uh that that's what
when when she refuses to go on a second
date with you
it's it's definitely the scheduling mix
up not the fact that she doesn't want to
go on a date with you probably here's
here's joe biden
i spoke with stacy this morning have a
great relationship we got our scheduling
mixed up i'm going to be i've caught for
their length this morning
we're all on the same page
and everything's fine
and um and yeah by the way the mask is
down again as always the minute that he
gets in front of human beings within
five feet he takes the mask down because
he is a doddering old fool okay so then
on to the event
so the event itself
is
morally egregious i mean truly morally
egregious
really disgusting if you're going to
label people on the other side of the
aisle actual black hating confederates
you might want some evidence other than
georgia got rid of some of the drop
boxes that were temporarily set up for
covid times
you might want to get rid
you might want to provide some evidence
other than georgia's election law which
passed a few months back and is
apparently less strict than delaware
election law
but
again this is all it's uh it's the
biggest lie the biggest lie all
elections will be stolen if you don't
allow me to steal elections is joe
biden's is joe biden's hedge okay so
vice president pamela harris she let off
he's just dragging her around at this
point trying to make kamala harris a
thing you're never making fetch a thing
man it is not happening fetch will not
be a thing
and she terrible she's just awful at
this i don't know why he bothers trying
to trot her out at this point as we will
see nobody else takes kamal o'hara
seriously like how not seriously is
kamala harris being taken if joe biden
were to keel over before the 2020
election before the 2024 election
democrats have somebody else in mind
already anyway here is kamala harris
making the absurdly stupid claim that uh
gop anti-voter laws are going to
disenfranchise 55 million people pulling
this number directly out of her ass
across our nation anti-voter laws could
make it more difficult for as many as 55
million americans to vote
that is one out of six people in our
country
um i i would like some
evidence that 55 million people are not
going to vote because republicans say
you have to show voter id
like some evidence that would be great
okay then joe biden gets up there and
again he's making a pitch on an issue no
one cares about no one cares about this
no one the entire stick here is can i
scare black people into voting for me
despite the fact i'm a crappy president
by the way i will tell you that the new
inflation stats are out again the reason
he's doing this is because he is dead in
the water come 2022 he's got real
problems come 2024 aside from his own
health which obviously is not good
according to the the brand new numbers
from the us government inflation climbed
to 7
in december seven percent on
on an annualized basis that is the
highest level since 1982 december was
the eighth month that inflation has been
at five percent or higher
that was driven by shelter used cars and
food
energy actually fell slightly
uh amazing amazing stuff so joe biden
he's again can he scare enough black
people into voting for him by shouting
that his opponents are jefferson davis
confederates he starts by saying we're
calling on congress to get this done
okay here's the problem dude congress is
controlled by your party you
you have 50 votes in the senate
you haven't you have a majority in the
house you are the president of the
united states you can't get people to
sign off on killing the filibuster
for your ridiculously usurpatious voting
law because no one backs it
here's joe biden trying to run against
the congress he controls
today
we call on congress to get done what
history will judge
pass the freedom to vote act
as our
old man shouts at clouds have we calling
congress to pass the freedom to vote
deathly
kiss him
okay then he gets even better then he
suggests that anyone who doesn't back
his proposal to kill the filibuster
which until five minutes ago democrats
were in love with
in fact before the democrats took the
senate the democrats used the filibuster
about a couple hundred times a year
against republican legislation
here's joe biden
saying that anyone who disagrees with
him on this bill is on the side of
george wallace again he served with
george wallace in the senate and uh he
used to brag about their relationship
bull connor and jefferson davis
jefferson davis that's right if you
don't back
his proposal to federalize all election
procedure
federalize ballot harvesting
force the federal government to overlook
every redistricting scheme in the united
states if you don't support all of that
you are on the side of people who
actively enslaved black people in the
united states and then fought a war
ending with the death of three quarters
of a million americans in order to
preserve slavery you're on the side of
those people if you don't back this old
white man who actually remembers the
civil war it is unclear which side joe
biden fought on at the time here is joe
biden
i ask every elected official in america
how do you want to be remembered
at consequential moments in history they
present a choice
do you want to be the sign the side of
dr king
or george wallace
do you want to be in the side of john
lewis
or bull connor
do you want to be the side of abraham
lincoln or jefferson davis
this is the moment to decide
this is the moment to decide i feel like
the the decision as to whether to be on
the side of
george wallace or martin luther king was
like 1968 and we came down on the side
as a country of martin luther king and
and when it came to john lewis versus
bull conor i feel like that decision was
made also
in that period and we came down on the
side of
of john lewis and i feel like the
decision about abraham lincoln versus
jefferson davis that decision came down
circa about 1865. so i'm not sure what
he's talking about he's not sure what
he's talking about all he knows is if he
can yell at black people maybe those
black people will go vote for an old
white man and his friends
it's truly incredible i don't know what
he thinks his electoral strategy here is
broadly speaking except he just keeps
doubling down on stupid they just keep
doubling down on stupid it's incredible
joe biden finishes up by saying trump
and the gop want to disenfranchise
anyone who votes against them
so again this is a huge lie this is a
huge lie the media won't call it out but
it is in fact the biggest lie that if
republicans win in the future it must be
because they disenfranchise millions of
people
the goal the former president's allies
is to disenfranchise anyone who votes
against them simple as that
the facts won't matter
your vote won't matter
they'll just decide what they want
and then do it
okay so that guy is a giant fail of a
human i mean i mean he's an immoral
human being if your job is that you go
out there and you suggest that your
political opponents are vicious brutal
slave pro-slavery racists because they
oppose you on your voting procedures act
in 2021 i don't know what to say about
you other than you are acting deeply
immorally and joe biden is an immoral
dirty scummy politician he really really
is i know we're supposed to pretend that
he's pure as the driven snow while his
son is running around the world picking
up bags of cash thanks to his last name
and admitting it on national television
i know we're supposed to pretend that
this dullard is somehow an intelligent
human being after riding barack obama's
coattails to fame being plucked from
obscurity specifically because he was an
older white gentleman
hey i i know we're supposed to pretend
that this person whose sole legislative
accomplishment his entire career was the
1994 crime bill which he then ran
directly away from in the last election
cycle in order to pander to the woke
base
but he is a dirty immoral scummy
politician pyroget and what he is doing
right now is dirty immoral and scummy i
know we're supposed to pretend that he
didn't say about again i'm never gonna
get over this i will not get over the
fact that he suggested that mitt romney
wanted to re-enslave black people
i'm never gonna get over that fact
that that that is like saying
that
mother teresa was very very interested
in promoting prostitution like what are
you talking about what are you even
saying right now
mitt romney wasn't saying that about
like donald trump you're saying that
mitt romney this guy has no limits
he's a congenital liar
he is immoral and and and the media
refused to call him out because there's
lap dogs it's unreal
okay but but people are starting to see
down the road and what they realize is
that the the daughtering elderlies who
currently run the democratic party
uh they are they're in trouble
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed